[موسيقى]
الاخبار اهلا بكم ما قالت او قال رئيس
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه ان من حق
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه تفتيش
مراكز تخصيب اليورانيوم على ان يتم ذلك
وفق اتفاق وقوانين محدده من جهه نفع
المتحدث باسم هيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه ان تكون طهران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه اتفقت على تركيب كاميرات
مراقبه جديده في المنشاه النوويه مؤكدا ان
ملف تقسيم اليورانيوم بنسبه 84% قد اغلق
في المقابل انتقد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو تصريحات مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رفع الجروس التي قال فيها
ان تنفيذه هجوم على منشات نوويه غير
قانوني واقل ان جروسيا بتصريحات غير
مناسبه واضاف ان اسرائيل ستواصل الدفاع عن
نفسها في مواجهه ما يدعو لابادتها حسب
تعبيره
نفى الجيش الاوكراني اي انسحاب جماعي
لقواته من مدينه باخمد بمنطقه اوكرانيا
وقال المتحدث باسم المجموعه الشرقيه
للقوات الاوكرانيه ان الجيش الاوكراني لا
يزال يسيطر على المدينه رغم صعوبه الوضع
مضيفا ان القتال يدور بشكل اساسي في ضواحي
المدينه
في الاثناء يواصل وزير الدفاع الروسي
جولته على جبهات دونيتسك والتقى عددا من
قاده الوحدات المقاتله الروسيه المتمركزه
فيما تسميه روسيا منطقه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه باوكرانيا وبحث شويجو مع قاده
العمليات دعم خطوط الانتاج وتهيئه الظروف
اللازمه للنشر الامن للجنود
قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا تواصل الاستعداد
لهجمات صاروخيه محتمله وتوجيه ضربات دقيقه
ومحدده لاوكرانيا مؤكده ان روسيا غير
التكتيكاتها من جهته جدد المتحدث باسم
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه على ضروره
الحصول على مقاتلات حديثه ومنظومات دفاع
جوي لمواجهه الضربات الروسيه
قال مؤسس شركه فاغنر العسكريه ان الشرطه
العسكريه الروسيه اعاقه وصول اشخاص انضموا
حديثا لقواته الى مركز فاقنار العسكري
واوضح ان شرطه العسكريه منعت وصول اولئك
المنضمين الى قواته وقامت بتوزيعهم على
وحدات عسكريه مختلفه وفيما يتعلق بامدادات
قواته بالذخيره قال ان معظم تلك الذخائر
لم تصل اليها اما بسبب البيروقراطيه او
الخيانه وفق تعبيره
شهدت العاصمه التونسيه مظاهره احتجاجيه
نظمتها جبهه الخلاص المعارضه للمطالبه
باطلاق سراح المعتقلين وبعضهم من قيادات
الجبهه ورفع المتظاهرون شعارات تدعو الى
اسقاط ما يصفونه بالانقلاب وقالت وزاره
الداخليه انه رغم عدم امتثال الجهه
المنظمه لقرار عدم الموافقه فانه جرى
تامين المظاهرات
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]